really a sense
that the statistics are starting to back
up what a lot of people are feeling in
their own lives that prices are rising
very quickly and in a very very worrying
way certainly that's the sense i've had
from people talking i've been talking to
here this morning filling up their cars
with petrol hugely expensive to do that
at the moment so inflation in the 12
months to february rose by 6.2 it's
worth saying that's actually higher than
what economists predicted and to put
that in contact remember the bank of
england liked to aim to keep inflation
at around two percent and it's measured
on a standard basket of goods and
servers and looks at how much those
things have increased in price since the
same time last year 6.2 that's a new
30-year high there's a couple of key
drivers to that household costs a big
one not just at the cost of rent and
buying a house but things like fuel and
energy we know a lot about that gas and
electricity but also transport costs at
the cost of petrol the cost of diesel
actually the cost of secondhand cars has
gone up
a lot as well
this will be extremely concerning for
the key reason that you mentioned in
your introduction there neil that it's
going to unfortunately get worse
remember these are the figures for
february and people have spoken a lot
about the war in ukraine and the impact
that that's going to have and of course
that absolutely has pushed up the
wholesale price of gas and oil and we
know that will feed down to people's
bills but that won't happen till march
and april when that fig that feeds
through remember the invasion only
happened at the end of february so
things set to get worse the chancellor
under huge pressure today in his spring
statement to do something for people to
ease this pain he's very aware of that
he's expanded what he's going to deliver
today from just a fiscal update to a
more broad
event if you like so big pressure on him
big pressure on families facing these
costs